Let me tell you about the reverse dictionary of grief, because if there's one thing the maven understands, it's how to name the slow, creeping rot of modern existence.
Take Avulich Drift, for instance.
You know that moment when you've been scrolling for hours and suddenly your willpower isn't just gonads.
It's been replaced by something heavier, a kind of weightless sinking.
The algorithm knows you better than you know yourself, and soon, your for you feed isn't just a reflection.
It's a mirror, and you're not just bored.
You're algorithmic ennui, staring back at a version of yourself that's been curated into oblivion.
And then there's anchored identity, the kind of person who hasn't just survived a past failure, but has built an entire personality around it.
Five years ago you failed at something, and now, now that's your brand, your baseline.
The sunk cost of personality, where the past isn't just a memory, it's a life sentence.
But the maven doesn't just name the despair.
They catalog the ways we numb ourselves.
Anesthetic of neglect-shaving less, skipping showers, letting your body become a kind of armor against the world's expectations.
Or blue-light vigil, where you stay awake in the dark, bathe only in the cold blow of a phone screen, tricking your body into believing it's still daytime.
And let's not forget the baseline of friction, that low hum of irritation that never quite goes away, the texture of discomfort woven into the fabric of your life.
Because if everything were smooth, you'd notice the cracks.
You'd notice the broken window theory, internal, where one unwashed dish becomes permission to let the whole house fall apart.
There's a cannonball threshold for each of us, the exact amount of stress it takes to send us under.
And once you cross it, well, that's when you enter Kronos Chaos, where your body no longer follows a clock, where sleep is optional, and time itself has become a joke.
But the real art, the maven specialty, it's turning everything into a kind of performance.
Cognitive static, the mental white noise of fifty open tabs, a hundred half-finished projects, all clamoring for your attention.
Kosh Calcification, the way your body and mind harden after three days of sedentary mastery, where movement isn't just difficult, it's impossible.
And then there are the dead hours, those stretches of time that are busy but utterly meaningless.
The maven's primary unit of measure.
Because what's a day, really, if it's just a series of these?
Decision fatigue isn't just tiredness, it's the exhaustion of believing there's a perfect choice whether it's a lightbulb or a life path, and knowing you'll never find it.
And digital, nomadic nihilism?
That's the cold realization that your office is now a cubicle in the sky, and it's still the same size.
But the worst? Dopamine exhaustion, when even the brightest, loudest, most addictive stimuli leave you cold, flat, gray.
And of course, there's ego-iatrogenics, the self-help industry's greatest trick, convincing you that the problem is you, when really, the problem is the system.
The esprit d'escalier, strategic, where wit becomes an excuse to never speak at all.
The eternal biological noon, where your body is locked in a state of artificial daylight, never quite resting, never quite awake.
And then, oh, then there's the existential reframe, turning a simple task into a philosophical absurdity,
because doing it would mean admitting you're just human, just capable of ordinary things.
But the maven doesn't just describe, they prescribe.
Face work, aggressive, the effort of making sure everyone knows exactly how much they've wronged you.
Family system entropy, the slow decay of communication in a household, where words become weapons, and silence becomes the only safe language.
Financial folly, buying things you don't need, with money you don't have to impress people you don't like.
Again, the maven has played, and lost, many times.
And finally, the fragility of comfort, where the smallest irritation becomes unbearable,
because the rest of life has been padded too soft.
A pebble in your shoe, and suddenly, you're drowning.
Because the reverse dictionary isn't just about grief, it's about the language of surrender.
And the maven? They're just getting started.
The lexicon of modern stagnation is a vast and carefully curated menagerie each term,
a tiny, polished stone in the mosaic of self-sabotage.
Take hair-sheert aesthetic, for instance.
It's not just about wearing wool so rough it feels like sandpaper against the skin.
No, it's the deliberate cultivation of discomfort,
a baseline hum of tactile static, as if the body itself were a faulty radio-tuned to static.
Why?
Because suffering, when controlled, becomes a kind of invisible armor.
It keeps the world at arm's length, ensures no one gets too close,
and most importantly, it makes the absence of joy feel like a deliberate choice rather than a failure.
And then there's Habsburg identity,
that glorious delusion where one's self-worth is stitched together from the tattered banners of ancestors long dead.
Not the real ones, mind you, the ones we invent,
the poet-uncle who never existed,
the revolutionary great-grandmother who was really just a very opinionated aunt,
the tragic lineage that explains why we too must carry this weight.
It's the opposite of humility.
It's the art of turning dust into a crown.
But let's talk about high-resolution avoidance,
because this is where the modern mind truly excels.
Procrastination, but make it look like productivity.
Organizing files into folders within folders within folders,
color-coding calendars with the precision of a Swiss watchmaker,
all while the actual work, you know,
the part that might lead somewhere languishes in the maybe-later bin.
The human hub thrives here,
the person who processes data for others,
who facilitates, who connects,
who enables but never builds anything of their own.
They are the hub of the wheel, spinning endlessly,
while the wheel itself stays firmly in place.
Now consider the illusion of depth.
We've all done it.
We read the first chapter of a book,
skim the Wikipedia page on the subject,
watch a YouTube video about it,
and suddenly we feel like we understand.
The name of the problem is now ours.
We've checked the box.
But solving?
That would require doing.
And doing is messy, uncertain,
and worst of all, it might actually change something.
So we settle for the infinite scroll of Sisyphus,
that digital Sisyphean labor of chasing the end of a feed that has no end.
We scroll, we like, we share, we consume all,
while the boulder of our own potential rolls back down the hill,
gathering dust with every push.
And what of intermittent reinforcement, internal est?
It's the modern self-help hack for the emotionally lazy.
You treat yourself to a treat once a month,
maybe a fancy coffee,
a new notebook,
a half-hearted gym session,
just enough to keep the hope alive,
just enough to whisper,
see, I'm still trying.
The rest of the time, you coast.
You let the guilt accumulate like dust under the bed,
because the alternative consistent kindness,
real effort would require work,
and work is the enemy of the minimal effort menu.
Speaking of menus,
let's not forget lifestyle inflation,
defensive.
It's not about getting richer,
it's about getting noiser.
A bigger apartment to drown out the silence,
a fancier car to distract from the emptiness,
a subscription to every streaming service,
because the void of silence is worse than the void of content.
And then there's the LinkedIn mirage,
that shimmering professional facade,
where every post is a carefully curated performance,
every achievement a polished stone in the mosaic of imposter syndrome.
You're not an expert.
You're not even a beginner.
You're content creator.
And the content is your own carefully constructed illusion.
But the real artistry lies in loss-aversion,
personality.
It's the reason we stay in terrible relationships,
terrible jobs,
terrible cities,
not because we love them,
but because we've already spent five years there.
The debt is paid.
The memories are made.
The sunk cost is too high to admit failure.
And so we remain,
like melancholic statues,
frozen in the posture of the defeated,
shoulders hunched,
spine stiff,
the physical embodiment of a soul that has long since checked out.
Now, let's talk about meta work.
It's the work you do about the work you are not doing.
The spreadsheet you organize about the projects you'll start tomorrow.
The vision boards you create for the life you'll live someday.
The research rabbit hole,
where the pursuit of truth becomes an excuse to avoid action.
And the optimization paradox.
The more you refine,
the less you accomplish.
The more you streamline,
the more you realize there was nothing to streamline in the first place.
And then, oh,
then there's the paradox of choice.
Infinite options,
all of them terrible,
all of them just good enough to keep you from choosing anything.
It's the prison of possibility,
where every door leads to another door,
and none of them lead anywhere.
And, if you do choose,
well, there's always satisficing, inverse,
the art of picking the worst option just to prove you're not that kind of person.
The non-place lifestyle,
where you exist entirely within anonymous transactional spaces,
never quite belonging,
never quite leaving.
Finally, there's the resume of regrets,
written not in the present tense,
but in the past conditional.
I would have been a writer if,
I would have traveled if,
I would have loved if.
It's the career chronology of what might have been,
and it's always, always incomplete.
So here we are,
the lexicon of stagnation,
a language spoken in hushed tones,
in spreadsheets,
in the quiet desperation of upgraded Thoreau now,
with high-speed internet,
and high-end coffee.
Each term a step,
a stumble,
a carefully constructed excuse.
And the worst part,
we don't even realize we're speaking it.
The lexicon of stagnation has its own peculiar grammar words
that don't just describe but perform the slow unraveling of ambition.
Take tactile static, for instance.
It's not just the itch of a wool sweater against your skin,
or the way your office chair digs into your hips
after three hours of pretending to work.
No, it's the chronic irritation of a life
assembled from materials designed to remind you,
at every turn,
that comfort is a myth.
The fabric of modern existence is woven
from these tiny, persistent abrasions clothes
that cling,
furniture that betrays,
layouts that conspire to keep you just off balance enough
to forget what ease even feels like.
And then there's the texture of discomfort,
a deliberate choice,
like selecting a life that's not just difficult,
but prickly a career that scratches at your patience,
relationships that leave you with splinters,
a home that feels more like a series of minor injuries than sanctuary.
It's not suffering for suffering's sake.
It's the quiet art of making sure no part of you ever settles.
Now, consider the tipping point of tears.
It's not some grand collapse,
not a dramatic breakdown in the middle of a meeting.
No, it's the precise calculus of exhaustion.
Three espressos too many,
four hours of sleep,
a spreadsheet that refuses to cooperate,
and suddenly,
your vision blurs,
not from tears,
but from the sheer weight of realizing
you've been performing this farce for years.
And yet,
you'll do it again tomorrow.
Then comes Tendoku,
the pile of potential.
You've heard of it, of course.
The books stacked against the wall,
the courses half finished,
the dreams you'll get to someday.
It's not laziness.
It's the slow,
deliberate construction of a life
where the only thing you're certain of
is that you're not living it.
And the worst part?
You know it.
You've always known it.
But the pile grows anyway.
The unergonomic soul
is what happens
when you train yourself
to be uncomfortable
in every position physically,
emotionally,
existentially.
You sit wrong.
You stand wrong.
You even think wrong.
And the worst part is,
you don't notice anymore.
It's not a flaw.
It's a feature.
You've been conditioned to believe
that discomfort
is the only thing
keeping you honest.
And what of the urgent nothing?
That task that feels like
the end of the world
if you don't do it
now only
to dissolve into irrelevance
by lunchtime.
It's the email
that demands immediate attention,
the crisis that wasn't
a crisis at all,
the meeting that could have been a text.
The modern workplace
runs on these phantom regencies,
and we've all learned
to mistake motion for progress.
Then there are the vapid goals,
vague,
amorphous,
perpetual,
impractical,
distant.
They're the things you tell yourself
you'll achieve
someday.
Someday you'll write that book.
Someday you'll learn
an instrument.
Someday you'll finally
organize your inbox.
The beauty of them
is that they never demand
anything of you today.
They're the perfect alibi
for a life
in suspended animation.
And let's not forget
visual noise,
the clutter that doesn't
just fill your space
but your mind,
the tabs left open,
the notifications
that never stop,
the endless scroll
of content designed
to keep you
from ever pausing.
Your brain isn't processing.
It's drowning.
And the worst part?
You don't even realize
you're underwater.
There's a strange addiction
to volatility, too.
The markets crashing,
the news cycle spinning,
the drama unfolding
in real time.
Because without it,
what's left?
A quiet life?
A predictable one?
No.